here in this video we will discuss and
showcase to you all the comparison of
singular point final form of godzilla
versus all the other incarnations over
the years and how he measures up to them
in size in this video titled how big is
singular point godzilla vs other
godzilla's but firstly let us explain a
little bit about this strange version of
the big g
he has four forms in the anime series
with each of them
being of a very different design than
the previous one
in his first form named godzilla
cordless he has an elongated marine
reptile physiology with traits similar
to whales and mosses the second one
godzilla amphibia strongly resembles
varan another kaiju which went crossed
with godzilla himself in this form his
tail now has three bobs instead of a fin
while his hind legs are smaller than his
four legs from the singular point four
forms of them two of them came to look
more like the classical design of being
upright with dorsal blades and they are
the third form which is terrestris and
the fourth and final one which is ultima
ultima is the one that we will take to
compare against the rest of the other
incarnations of the big g
the first time he was seen in his final
form he was 45 meters tall or 150 feet
in height and in the final episode he
was a hundred meters or 328 feet tall so
how does he compare with the rest let's
see
versus the showa era godzilla's the
showa godzillas include the first one
from the 1954 movie which had more or
less the same designs going up in
successive movies till the late 1970s or
maybe just 1975
and they were all more or less the same
in size with ultima as he was seen in
the initial episodes when he was
transforming from terrestris they were
all 50 meters tall or 164 feet and when
compared to ultima from his initial
episodes at 45 meters or 150 feet
they were more or less the same in size
but they were only half that of the size
of the one that was seen in the final
episode with ultimate during that time
being a hundred meters tall
more than twice his initial height
versus godzilla 2000 and godzilla
gmxg he was also let's say 40 meters or
130 feet taller than godzilla from gmk
which stood at around 60 meters or 200
feet tall
which would also be the same size
difference against tristar godzilla and
ziller from final wars who were both 60
meters tall well some might say that
these sky jews were 70 meters but mine
key will stick to the 60 meter size
now we will come to the bigger godzillas
which was seen in the early heisei
period which includes the ones from the
movies the return of godzilla godzilla
vs biollante and godzilla vs king
ghidorah these early heisei entries were
all 80 meters tall or around 262 feet in
height
but there would still be a difference in
length and mass as we can see the
godzilla ultima has a very long tail
with some estimates putting its tail at
around 300 meters or 1000 feet long
now let's see the first version of
godzilla that is bigger than ultima and
this one is the hyper evolving specimen
from the 2016 movie shin godzilla this
monster along with its spin-off snow
godzilla that made an appearance in
another anime were both
118.5 meters tall or 388 feet in height
and we will now compare with the most
recent and undoubtedly the most famous
godzilla version which is most of us
godzilla so okay master vs big g was
initially said to be 108 meters tall in
a 2014 movie but was then rebranded as
120 meters tall or 393 feet in height in
king of the monsters and later in
godzilla vs kong this would put the
legendary kaiju at 20 meters taller than
singular points ultima
and now finally we will see the only
other godzilla which is undoubtedly
taller longer and bigger than ultima and
that is none other than another anime
godzilla godzilla earth standing at 300
meters tall or a thousand feet and
having a tail length which would be
twice or thrice that figure this
godzilla is still the biggest of them
all and with that we come to the end of
this video of the comparison of sizes
between singular point godzilla and the
rest